dunder mifflin this is pam pam it's
michael help me i need help right now
michael what's wrong i'm hurt i have
hurt myself
oh my god okay wait wait wait wait this
is not looking good michael do you need
me to call an ambulance no i want you to
pick me up okay
wait a second i thought you said that
you were hurt i am hurt
i'm sorry pam i want to come to work but
i need you to come and pick me up
no god hey whoa michael oh god it's okay
it's jim just say again really loudly uh
what happened okay
i burned my foot
very badly on my foreman grill and i now
need someone to come and bring me into
work you burned your foot on a foreman
grill
i enjoy having breakfast in bed i like
waking up to the smell of bacon sue me
and since i don't have a butler i have
to do it myself
so
most nights before i go to bed i will
lay six strips of bacon out on my george
foreman grill
then i go to sleep
when i wake up i plug in the grill i go
back to sleep again
then i wake up to the smell of crackling
bacon
it is delicious it's good for me it's
perfect way to start the day
today i got up i stepped onto the grill
and i clamped down on my foot that's it
i don't see what's so hard to believe
about that him could you come get me
uh i have to stay here and answer the
phone okay could someone come and get me
please ryan michael you should stay home
and rest there's no toilet paper here
could ryan tell ryan to bring toilet
paper could you tell him that can you
hop i tried hopping kevin and i bumped
my elbow against the wall and now my
elbow
has a protruderance
no one wants to pick me up
what is going on
what is going on
michael is um sick and he wants one of
us to rescue i'm not sure i'm
hold on michael i am coming
and
i have a mission to accomplish make sure
this party gets rolling and i will be
back shortly ew
where are you going you want me to come
with oh
this is listen i forgot to tell you the
plan for this saturday you me bar beers
buzzed
wings shots drunk waitresses hot
football cornell hofstra slaughter
then quick nap at my place and we hit
the t sound no
i don't want to do any of that
duh
which is why i was joking about doing it
just stop stop
just stop doing it you're going to drive
me crazy
fine i'll just go sit at my desk and be
quiet
sorry i annoyed you with my friendship
[Music]
excuse me
and i'm also sorry
that a lot of people here
for some reason think it's funny to
steal someone's personal property and
hide it from them
here's a little news flash it's not
funny
in fact it's pretty freaking unfunny
that was an overreaction
i'm gonna hit the break room does
anybody want anything
ma'am you good
yeah sure okay
okay everybody tonight's event is to
benefit the boy scouts of america again
we do that every year well they need our
money they don't have cookies like the
girl scouts it'd be nice to do something
for people who are actually suffering
well oscar if you don't like it then you
should concentrate on winning
because the person at the end of the
evening with the highest chip count will
receive 500 to donate to the charity of
their choice oh
and another fun thing
we at the end of the night are going to
give the check to an actual group of boy
scouts right toby we're gonna actually i
didn't think it was appropriate to
invite children since it's uh
you know there's gambling and alcohol
and it's in our dangerous warehouse and
it's a school night
and you know hooters is catering
you know is that enough is that enough
should i keep going
why are you the way that you are
honestly every time i try to do
something fun or exciting you make it
not that way
i
hate so much about the things that you
choose to be
okay come on come on man why didn't you
go in there what everybody was scared
out of their way everyone okay
uh i have an announcement
apparently
in business school they don't teach you
how to operate a toaster oven
because some smart sexy temp left his
cheese pita
an oven instead of timing it for the
toaster thing
[Laughter]
wow
okay
well i guess they don't teach how to
operate a toaster oven in business
that's exactly what i said hey did you
miss that day there ryan were you
absolutely toast heaven 101 you failed
i'm so sorry
hey i know it'll impress everybody i'll
start a fire
oh man bad idea bad idea jeans uh i have
it song attention everyone that i want
to sing that i wrote especially for this
occasion when i was up there among the
flames
ready
ryan started the fire
it was always burning since the world
returning ryan started the fire
it was always fun everybody was turning
i can't believe i started the fire
oh my god uh oh my god fire oh fire oh
my goodness what's the procedure what do
we do people are dead oh how did that
happen
no we don't know that the smoke could be
coming through an air duct oh my god
okay it's happening everybody stay calm
what's the procedure everyone what's the
procedure
calm down no no michael no touch the
handle if it's hot there could be a fire
in the hallway
what does warm mean oh my gosh
oh here's the door check that one out
how's the handle it's warm okay go to
the bathroom oh another option that's
right
jeez okay
on everyone
leave it woman get out of the way go go
go things can be replaced phyllis people
human lives however can
ah my hand that's hot
this one's hot too okay we're trapped
everyone for himself
have you ever seen a burn victim
okay
procedural procedure
exit options where do we go
a rag a damp rag perhaps
let's remember those procedures what are
the options
that's the wrong way we've already tried
that remember your exit points exit
[Music]
how about 911
[Music]
what do we do use the surge of fear and
adrenaline to sharpen your decision
making okay i am not dying here come on
oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
attention
employees of dunder mifflin
this has been a test of our emergency
preparedness there is no fire it was
only a simulation
what fire not real this was merely a
training exercise
so what have we
learned oh come on it's not real stanley
don't have a heart no no no no no you
will not die staley stanley you will not
die stanley stanley barack is president
you are black sadly i'm going to give
him mouth about no no don't give him out
the mouth for this you're gonna swallow
his tongue open your mouth michael swan
don't follow him
i'm fine leave me alone
you